when stories about his sex life appeared
in the tabloids
max mosley decided to fight back
at great personal expense he stood up to
the newspapers
that had alleged the sex parties he'd
been involved with
had a nazi theme it was a case he won
i had the impression from the outset
that as soon as i
challenged the original story that the
entire resources
of news international news group
newspapers
were then deployed effectively to try
and destroy me
fascism in great britain has advanced
more rapidly mosley was the youngest son
of oswald mosley
who led the british union of fascists in
the 1930s
but max mosley chose a different path as
a racing driver
who went on to lead the sport
after the deaths in 1994 of ayrton senna
and roland ratzenberger on consecutive
days
on the track at imola in san marino
mosley led the sports rethink
on driver safety max became an important
figure through
the last part of my career the main part
of my career and was a
formidable character who took control
of the sport and together with bernie
ecclestone
shaped it the way they wanted it to and
took on
anybody who tried to stop them after max
mosley stepped away
from f1 he helped support victims of
phone hacking
the tabloids saw him as the enemy of the
press
people didn't stop going after him you
know and that continued
it was a kind of he was the main man to
get
he did take these things personally but
he wouldn't let that show
and he did channel that energy not into
rage
but i think helping other victims
oppress intrusion or injustice
many people would have stepped away from
the battles that max mosley fought
but he stuck to his beliefs
whatever the personal cost tom parmenter
sky news